[Music]
we all have that wacky friend who thinks
they're so I'll turn it because when you
ask what's your favorite Christmas movie
they reply die hard slow clap for that
guy in is crazy off-the-wall opinions
your mental you are that you're one of
those people who thinks the Star Wars
prequels with the terrible puppet Yoda
are better than the originals with the
also terrible puppet Yoda little does
your wacky friend know though that
there's an even better alternative
Christmas movie that movie is die hard
to die harder throughout this video I'll
be discussing why the seminal sequel has
more in common with the story of our
Lord and Savior than you could even
imagine so sit back your [ __ ] and listen
to my new crazy alternative answer I'm
so lucky me reason 1 it stars Jesus
throughout die hard 2 Jesus makes
several appearances the plot film
centers around rescuing a middle-east
inish man named general Ramon Esperanza
while some Liars may have you believe
that he is Russian or some other
nationality that America hated during
1992 I think that he actually symbolizes
Jesus our Lord and Savior persecuted
throughout the film we see that the evil
John McClane wants to put an end to his
holiness his holiday home and end his
return to freedom depicted as a villain
we see that the general or should I say
Jesus is nice to those around him when
he gives kind words to that soldier
while some would argue that he murders
the soldier I believe that he is in fact
filling him with the Holy Spirit and
sending him on his way to heaven
murdered much in the same way Jesus was
we see the great generals suffer for our
sins on Christmas and ascending to
heaven
wrapped in a beautiful light reason to
the
she's in it one of the more modern
characters conjured up for Christmas is
the Grinch this heartwarming story tells
the tale of a grumpy greedy grinning
Grinch that wants to steal Christmas
from all throughout the original work we
see the Grinch go on a journey of
self-discovery as he learns to love the
holidays once more similar to this we
see the character captain carmine
Lorenzo turn from belem to trusted ally
as he learns the joy of Christmas and
murder starting off as a cliched
authoritative jerk you will fall in love
with Captain Lorenzo as he lets you
learn the joy of giving once more giving
traffic tickets that is this brilliant
depiction whilst infringing on copyright
reminds us of just how Christmasy
diehard 2 is reason 3 it's set at
Christmas
I guess I'm beginning to scrape the
barrel a bit here but did you know this
is gonna blow your mind that die hard to
die harder is set at Christmas you
didn't well guess what in fact it is so
that's really Christmassy reason for it
has an old person riding something in
the sky during die hard too we see a
graceful old British woman on her
journey through the night sky before she
is casually killed in a plane crash
however had her journey been successful
she would have most likely landed travel
to a child's home and handed out
presents metaphorically she clearly
symbolizes Santa I just feel sorry for
her grandchildren who would have awoken
to the fact that not only was their
grandmother dead for that they also
didn't have any presents as they were
most likely all on the plane this
reminds us that Christmas is full of
tragedy to the perfect Christmas message
reason 5 - Shh - shut up mate - shut Oh
look yet if you're one of those people
who think giving die hard is an answer
for your favorite Christmas movie it's
really creative and unique then you need
to sort your sodding life out you're not
original you're not clever you're a
complete idiot billions of people exist
like you who think this
Oh special well your not tell you what
mate stop saying stuff like The Hobbit
movies or better than Lord of the Rings
and ant-man is actually bought popular
than Superman it makes you look like an
idiot desperate for attention with your
alternative opinions because you have
nothing else going on in your life
you're pathetic and I hope you have a
terrible Christmas anyway make sure you
subscribe my channel yeah thanks so that
was my list of five reasons why die hard
2 is more Christmassy than die hard one
bit of a terrible video wasn't it
probably shouldn't have released it but
I did and I just want to say thank you
to everyone who's checked down my
website this year I've seen a huge
increase in traffic which is all down to
you sub thanks please like and share
this video to spread the joy of
Christmas and I hope you have a
brilliant year